James is with us in Charleston South
Carolina wonderful town hey James how
are you I'm doing good Dave how you
doing better than I deserve what's up
well I've been an interesting few months
I learned I'm gonna be a father come
March next year and I know right the
first time too so don't do the whole
process of at least getting ready
financially and all of that needed for
when the kid comes and in relation to
that so my my in-laws they've sent me a
letter promise of a very very generous
gift they essentially want to buy for my
wife and I a brand new vehicle that is
in their mind at least it's about just
enough for protecting their grandkid
around it'll be their first grandkid -
I'll mention oh that's nice it is really
nice
we're a little bit of the I'll just say
a little bit attention comes in is the
fact that they've done very well with
money their whole life they're actually
multimillionaires out RVing living their
dream right now and without knowing you
they've pretty much followed all your
baby steps and all that stuff
except with relation to what your belief
is on how to uh
the proper way will say to to buy
vehicles if you're not a millionaire
that's at that point on they've always
believed that the right way to do it is
to buy a vehicle brand-new outright
every time that we go for a oil change
and they talk to the mechanic who is
normally the one at the dealer he would
tell them all the extra little things
that you know maybe worry em and they'd
say fix it right there
basically just keep the car as pristine
so always putting reliability at the
forefront and affordability if you will
especially for where they were in life
on the back end and they're requiring of
us when we get this new vehicle to
follow those exact same specs total
insurance they they want total
compensation the most expensive details
like that so I'm just trying to get
an idea whenever I see them the best way
to start a conversation you know the
fact that I'm generous but I don't fully
agree with the terms that are being put
on with this gift you know and I think
you start with just a very hit this is
your parents right this is my wife's
parents oh yeah well your wife needs to
lead as much of the conversation as as
possible because otherwise you're going
to end up being the evil son-in-law okay
um and she needs to say how grateful
that you guys are and you need to say
how grateful we are but and what I would
do it is I would probably just use a
little shock effect and that would be
guys thank you so much this is an
unbelievable offer and you're so kind
and we're so glad you're so excited
about the baby we're excited for that
you're going to be grandparents and we
can't wait for you to spend time with a
grandbaby and thank you so much we're
gonna have to turn down the gift though
we're not gonna be able to accept it I'm
sorry
thank you so much for offering it though
you're so kind and you're generous well
why why won't you take it we just want
to be a blessing right well we don't you
know there's just too many strings
attached to it and I'm afraid we're
gonna disappoint you with the way we
handle the car and because we just don't
do cars the way y'all do cars and and
you know it's okay there's a really kind
offer of you though and just take it all
right take it off the table and and in
and and unless they come back around and
just say okay no strings because a gift
with strings is not a gift that makes
sense true I mean it's a manipulation at
that point they don't mean to be there
they think they're being they think
they're coaching you they think they're
giving you good a good practice to put
in place but the request is unreasonable
because it invades your life and that's
what you're saying that's what you're
saying you're saying I have the right to
make these decisions about my own car
and you're taking away my right to make
those decisions so
it's a boundaries violation from a Henry
cloud perspective on the book boundaries
but probably what I would do is just
just very kindly real low-key don't make
a big deal about it and just how great
you guys are so sweet thank you so much
what a wonderful offer absolutely
incredible
you're gonna be just great grandparents
and we're so excited for you to be the
grandparents and we're excited about
this baby but we're just gonna have to
turn down the gift I'm so sorry
thank you though for the offer don't you
know what the real thing is gonna be
that they're gonna fall out of their
freakin chair right yeah it's a shock
effect and and I'm not and if they don't
come back around this fine don't take
the gift cuz I'm with you I wouldn't
take it under those circumstances but I
want to do it in such a way that there's
no rough edges in my turndown you follow
me yeah I understand it's not like
you're invading my privacy you don't get
to tell me how to handle a car I mean
none of that kind of thing
you don't have that going in your voice
now so I don't think you would with them
but I really want your wife to handle as
much of this conversation as she's able
to handle because it's her parents and
as quiet as you can possibly be and sit
there and smile and nod would be great
and if you need to step in and just kind
of put a bow on it at the end that'd be
fine too but but I really want because
I'm telling you man it she'll go a lot
further than not and they'll accept it
more from her and then if they come if
they come in and go well we'll give it
to you with no gifts we just really
think this is a good way to do it and
say you know we understand why you're
saying this and I get why you guys did
it
I just don't want to have that I don't
want it being a situation where I'm
going to disappoint you because then if
I don't handle the cart just right then
you're gonna be upset and that's I don't
want to be in that position where I can
sit I'm set up to lose here and I don't
want to lose so you know if you can give
it to us and not be looking at us like
we're idiots the whole time we're
driving it then that's fine but if you
can't that's okay - everything's okay
we're going along fine - you made this
phone call everything's fine
you know and you know and that because
it's not worth it you're gonna lock out
a car payment I mean you're I have
people looking over your shoulder every
time you turn the lugnut
on a stupid thing and it just takes the
fun out of it